so I want to revisit something I said at
the top of the show yesterday and I I
admitted that I did think I had thought
I used to think that some of trumps
president Trump's anti media rhetoric
was overblown and and even dangerous
potentially but the media's handling of
Brett Kavanaugh and that this whole
story has been just so completely
terrible that it's proven him right in
every respect about everything he said
about the media has been proven right
they really are an enemy of the people
to use a phrase that he's gone back to
many times and it's a phrase that the
media gets very upset when he says that
but III think they've I think they've
proven it they they they are so fully
invested in their left-wing ideology
they're so fully invested in you know
those convictions that they cannot be
ethical or honest or objective even if
they even if they tried to be I don't
think they could be and they don't try
they're not interested in trying so with
the Cavanaugh scandal the media has just
completely abandoned any semblance of
objectivity or integrity or anything
else this is not the first time they've
done this they've done this before there
are many examples let's just recall one
other before we get to this one probably
the most egregious example prior to this
was Ferguson recall how the media in
that case took the very first version of
the story that they received and they
repeated it and this is a story given to
them by by the accomplice by Mike
Brown's friend who had just robbed a you
know helped in this strong-arm robbery
and was obviously trying to cover for
himself and that should have been
obvious to any into any experienced
journalist hearing the story of the
friend who was got in trouble with the
police for one reason or another you
should think well let's this story might
not be let's let's let's back up before
we repeat this story let's let's back up
here for a minute but they didn't do
that they took the story and they
repeated it hands up don't shoot and so
on and so forth
they kept repeating it as absolute fact
even when it became clear even when it
was confirmed that the story was false
fabricated made up they still repeated
it ad nauseam there were people burning
down buildings because of the of the the
false narrative that they constructed
and they kept repeating it so what's
happening now well now they are waging
an all-out war an explicit smear
campaign against Cavanaugh at the behest
of the Democrat Party and for the
purposes and no other purpose other than
this and that is to keep a an abortion
opponent off of the court and so that's
what this is all about now what what
else can you call them but enemies I
mean there's certainly enemies to the
truth there are enemies of decency they
lie destroy distort they sow discord so
what that's what enemies do you know
that's what that's what an enemy of the
American people that's what an enemy of
America would do right that's what they
that's what they try to do they they
they they bring destruction and chaos
which is what the media does and I don't
think now listen because sometimes we
can go too far in the direction we talk
about fake news and we say well it's all
fake news and everything they say is
wrong and and they're just all the time
just inventing stories out of thin air
and know that that's that's not correct
okay
it's it's not you go pick up if you
actually ever ever did decide to read
the New York Times you're not gonna find
cover to cover as it were nothing but
total mythology that that's that's not
how fake quote/unquote fake news works
that's not generally how media bias
works most of the time with media bias
you know you read a story you hear story
in the news most of the time you can be
pretty sure that 85 to 95 percent of
what they're saying is basically true
maybe even a hundred percent is true but
most this is how usually worked with
media bias they're very selective in the
stories they tell us and in the ways
that they present those stories ok
that's usually how media bias works but
on occasion when they really feel
compelled to it when they have a very
strong ideological interest and also
when they have a strong ratings interest
as well and when those things intersect
then it's game over but but on on those
occasions they will they are willing to
go with a completely made-up story not a
story that they necessarily made up but
a story that was given to them that was
that is that it's very very likely
fabricated so hands up don't shoot is
one example of that where they were
willing to go with a fabricated
dangerous story and roll with it because
of ideological reasons and because it
was great for ratings and now they're
doing the same thing with Brett
Kavanaugh and especially with Julie
sweating so that that's Exhibit A Monday
night MSNBC aired an interview with with
Julie sweat Nick the you know the third
Cavanaugh accuser sweat Nick's story is
totally ridiculous literally
unbelievable in the sense that it cannot
be believed she claims that Kavanaugh
and his friends were members of an
organized rape gang that would
systematically drug and brutalize women
at parties that those women including
sweatin occur self would continue
attending despite knowing that they'd
probably be raped okay that's the story
that she tells the NBC News admitted
they could not find a single person to
corroborate her account they could not
find a single person to substantiate
anything she said they could not find a
single other eyewitness there are no
police reports there are no nothing from
this period of time when you've got
these apparently terrorist boys running
around raping people left and right they
also said that sweat Nix account had
changed in the last week what she told
NBC News was not completely consistent
with what she had said through her
lawyer avenatti just only a week ago yet
they chose to err and this is I'm
talking most perfect example of how the
fake news things were thing works
nobody is is claiming
not an irrational person is claiming
that NBC News is the originator of sweat
Nick's story no sweat Nick who appears
to be a bit of a nutcase she she came
forward with this story and they said
let's go with it
now these people at NBC News these are
smart people these aren't stupid people
they know what they're doing so they're
just like you and I the first time they
hear the story they're just like you and
I they know that okay come on really
before you even get into a lack of
corroborating evidence lack of witnesses
so forth before you even get into that
they're gonna have the same reaction any
other normal person with a brain would
and they're gonna say really but and if
this accusation came out against a
liberal nominee for the Supreme Court or
a liberal politician they would
absolutely spike that story and for good
reason they'd be justified in doing so
because it's completely unsubstantiated
and it is ridiculous on its face but
here they went with it
even though it is libelous despicable
propaganda they reported it they
presented it as hard news and so yeah
fake news not only that but but as I
mentioned yesterday sweat Nick on NBC
was clearly regurgitating blatantly
regurgitating stories that she had heard
herself in the media the previous week
so she you know she used certain key
phrases she called Cavanaugh a quote
sloppy drunk a quote mean drunk she said
they he pushed girls into walls and all
this stuff those are those are stories
allegations descriptions that the media
had been churning out and and reporting
quote-unquote over the last week so she
was taking those lines and those stories
from the media and repeating it back to
the media and they were then repeating
it as if it was new information
meanwhile the the rest of the left-wing
media have been digging into these
accusations that Cavanaugh threw ice at
somebody at at a party three decades ago
originally now this has changed a little
bit I think it was originally that he
threw a beer on somebody and now
was ice and then maybe it was a beer
first and I became ice or an ice and I
don't know it's it's all confused but he
according to these people that are
coming out through CNN and the left-wing
media Cavanaugh was drunk at some point
in his college years and he threw
something at somebody okay
CNN openly questioned whether
Cavanaugh's ice throwing history should
be disqualifying that was a question was
asked by that billion by a CNN anchor to
the Democratic senator Hirono who just
as a side note this senator Hirono who I
never was never on my radar prior to all
this but apparently she's we're talking
about one of the biggest hacks and Liars
in all of American politics and and I
didn't even really know about her but
now she's kind of risen to the surface
much like pond scum and anyway she she
that's that's a metaphor I'm not saying
she's pond scum I'm just saying she's in
a way behaved like pond scum let's just
say she was asked is this disqualifying
and she said well this is why we need an
FBI investigation okay this is why we
need an FBI investigation is to find out
whether there was weather weather ice
was thrown then consider M Allison
cammarata on CNN she someone came on on
CNN a voice of reason came on CNN and
said that well to talk about him
throwing ice is quote a distraction it's
a degradation of the debate Cammarata
said this is what she said she said I
disagree I think it's part and parcel of
the entire thing I think that if you're
known as a belligerent mean fighting
drunk that's relevant I think that it's
relevant to then a woman who says that
you would corner her and put your hand
over her mouth somehow that that I think
makes more sense than if you were just a
fun drunk who always fell right asleep
okay so I think it is relevant now first
of all I don't think a fun drunk as
someone who falls asleep that's a lame
drunk but put that to the side
she is directly saying she's actually
saying that a guy throwing ice when he's
drunk 30 years ago is an indication that
he might be a serial rapist that's what
she's saying another side bar for a
moment all of this hand wringing over
Cavanaugh's alleged aggression as a
teenage boy he's supposed fights that he
got into or whatever it is all so stupid
in fact I would be more suspicious of a
guy who never got into fights as a
teenager than a guy who did because it's
the most normal thing in the world most
normal thing is for a guy a you know men
between the ages certainly starting
interact well I don't my son is five
years old you should see you should see
now when it's when his little cousin
comes over and they just they just beat
the hell out of each other I mean all in
good fun but as soon as they see each
other they're on top of each other
they're wrestling around I either do
whatever that's what boys do and that
doesn't change like that's how it is my
son is in that age now I mean he was in
that age essentially or Suzy came up day
after he's born he was like he was that
age and that's how it remains for like I
mean into your well I mean into your 20s
that that's how it is so that that's
normal and it's it it's especially as a
teenager all it indicates is that there
is a presence of testosterone in this
person which again is normal I mean when
I was a kid I mean I can think of so
many example I once I punched my friend
in the head when I was a kid because he
fouled me during a pic a basketball game
and then he wouldn't admit that he
fouled me and because I look I was that
guy in pickup basketball every time I
went for a shot I would I would say an
one because I got fouled all the time
all right I mean I was taller than some
of the other kids I play with so they
thought they had to foul me so but you
know and I would always demand right
like if I'm fouled and then of course he
claimed they didn't foul he did so what
I do it punched him in the head
right look and then he punched me back
and and I don't know I was fifteen years
old thirty minutes later we were fine
thirty minutes later we were we were
hanging out it was fine
we were laughing about it I mean this
stuff happen all the time it's normal
boys are aggressive physical this is
what they do so what we would we would
almost come to blows over over video
games it's a big one over discussions
like whether DC or marvel is the best we
were play these we would play these
pickup football games and the only
reason we played them was it was really
just an excuse to let out our aggression
you know kid guys two of his teeth
knocked out one time there was another
time or you know I a guy was tackled and
then I jumped on the dog pile after he'd
already been tackled which I think is
fair and pick up football I mean you of
course you jump with a dog pile right
yeah he was already down but we don't
have refs so he was mad about that the
next time I had the ball he came and I
was going out of bounds he came and
tackled me anyway out of bounds and I
fell into a bush and I thought I broke
my arm and so we got into a scuffle and
then again 30 minutes later we're fine
right this is just what boys do I'm not
saying of course that any of that makes
sexual assault okay I'm just saying that
none of that can be considered evidence
that a guy is a sexual assault er
because it is so completely normal and I
would say even healthy I'll put it to
you this way a boy is going to get his
aggression out one way or another and
it's better to get it out by scuffling
over pickup basketball games then to get
it out through some other means like I
don't know like a school shooting for
instance I mean boys have this
aggression and this sort of violence in
them and that's one of the reasons why
it's now I'm getting so sidetracked here
but it's just important to me it's one
of the reasons why we have why it's
important to get kids into sports and
football and basketball and whatever
even soccer if you have to know not
soccer but do any other sport one of the
reasons we do that is is because they
have this aggression there's sort of
violence in them and let's channel it
through
saw in some healthy and competitive way
and a fun way and that's why it's so
intensely unfair to dig up this kind of
stuff from a guy's teenage years you
have no idea what it's like to have that
raging testosterone going on unless
you're a guy in which case you do know
what it's like so stop acting shocked
when you find out that Cavanaugh was a
lot like you were at that age and I'm
not talking about the sexual assault I'm
saying I don't think the sexual assault
happened I'm saying all this other stuff
is not an indicator of sexual assault
for the reasons that I'm describing so
leaving the sexual assault with the uh
that's uncorroborated unsubstantiated
talk about the things that are that are
arguably substantiated where there's
some kind of witnesses or whatever and
all we have there is just he drank and
he was and he could be aggressive like
that's that's the only thing potentially
that there's that there's corroboration
for and so what so he's exactly like
every other boy and you know what if
Cavanaugh went to more parties than you
did you might say well look I wasn't
gonna you know when I was a
fifteen-year-old boy I wasn't going to
two parties and stuff like that well you
know why it's probably only because you
weren't invited to them or your parents
wouldn't let you go but you would have
gone I mean let's be honest you would
have gone but you did do stupid
aggressive things don't say you didn't
you did and that doesn't make you our
rapist and it doesn't make Cavanaugh a
rapist and it's just it is so unfair and
the people that are doing it they must
know how unfair it is I mean maybe it's
possible if you've got some maybe with
some women if they've never been around
guys that much and they have a really
oblivious sense of what guys are like
and if they're not a mother and they
didn't have brother it's like maybe
there could be some women who are really
actually surprised and shocked and
scandalized to find out that cab you
know Kavanagh made dirty jokes ins your
book and got into a fight in a bar like
maybe there are some women yeah because
that's just not how they
but to any guy any guy no guy who is
honest could say that they're surprised
by that but all of the Cavanaugh
coverage has been in this vein the
left-wing news channels and newspapers
they're acting as hitmen for the
Democrat Party they're digging up even
the most irrelevant accusations and
rumors and they're reporting them as
fact all of this stuff is just
prejudicial there's there's a reason why
okay there's a reason why and I know
we're not in a court of law but ideally
if we're if we're going for what's ideal
what's fair the court of public opinion
should adopt some of the principles that
you find in a court of law and I'll tell
you one of them one of those principles
innocent till proven guilty should be
won the other one is you cannot allow
prejudicial and irrelevant evidence into
the discussion so if this was in a court
of law if Brett Kavanaugh was being
tried on charges of rape which he's not
and never will be because there's no
evidence and there's no basis for it but
if he were there is no way his lawyers
are gonna let the lawyer and the judge
there's no way the judge if it's a
halfway competent judge the judge in
that trial would never let this story
about ice being thrown into the into the
courtroom probably wouldn't let the
stuff in the yearbook either
because it's not relevant doesn't prove
anything and all it does is it just
prejudice as the jury up it paints a
picture with irrelevant details and it
exploits the naivete and the gullibility
and the obliviousness of the jury so
that if there is anyone on the jury
stupid enough to say to themselves like
Alison camerata if Alison Cammarata was
on the jury and she would say well he
threw ice maybe he's a rapist like the
court courtrooms know that there are
people that dumb out there in the world
and that's why they would never let that
into the courtroom probably the
prosecutor would love to put it in but
defense attorney judge would never allow
it for this reason
you know the work the worst thing of all
I think is that is that the media
believes that they somehow have the
right to behave this way and yet to
remain free from criticism while they
behave this way they chalk it all up to
you know their any attack against them
they say is an attack on the First
Amendment but they are the ones
undermining the First Amendment by using
it as a cover so that they can lie and
slander they're the ones undermining the
First Amendment by abusing it like this
and they say that all this anti media
sediment is in the country is just the
result of President Trump no the anti
media sentiment is the result of their
own behavior people detest them because
they behave detestably it's funny how
that works
people have contempt for contemptible
behavior and the media has been nothing
if not contemptible throughout this
whole cabin else saga thanks for
listening everybody Godspeed